le futuroscope est ouvert le futuroscope
c'est à 7 kilomètres de poitiers c'est
un ensemble impressionnant d'équipements
aux lignes futuristes comprenant aussi
bien des salles de spectacles de sport
que divers bâtiments administratifs le
public était convié aujourd'hui à
découvrir pour antenne de geneviève mike
todd dernier avait choisi pour ce lieu
du futur des enfants comme premier
témoin j'ai ressenti d'aléas d'avancé à
très grande vitesse alors que nous
marchions tout
futur c'est quelque chose de magnifique
le futur ces enfants ils sont entrés de
plain pied sous la bulle du futuroscope
ces écrans digitaux il ne les avait
jamais utilisée pourtant au bout de 30
secondes
il savait les faire fonctionner rien de
temps
rien tout est naturel
et qu'on s'envoie si l'uci au fond les
bulles ou se feront des expériences sur
le temps le théâtre alphanumérique face
à un plan d'eau en construction le
cristal noir de l'architecte georges la
mac dans lequel nous pénétrerons tout à
l'heure
l'institut international de l'innovation
et sous le chapiteau une usine
entièrement robotisée jeu cette maquette
le premier collège câble et d'europe qui
ouvrira en septembre et recevra 400
élèves
des galaxies du futur avec des
expositions sur la santé la recherche
les biotechnologies et des jeux des jeux
électroniques pour les petits et pour
les grands
aujourd'hui déjà on peut s'amuser et
dans le cristal assister à une séance de
cinéma grâce à un appareil canadia
l'imax qui projette du 70 mm sur le plus
grand écran plat d'europe 600 mètres
carrés
il a fallu deux ans pour ouvrir le
chantier au public il en faudra deux
autres pour le terminer cinquante
entreprises sont employés en permanence
sur le site sans véritable casse ce qui
est miraculeux pas bêtement honnête
depuis deux ans on a eu une foulure et
un bras cassé je pense qu'en deux ans
sur un chantier de cette importance
c'est le minimum qu'on puisse y qu'on
puisse avoir
tout cela pour créer en pl poueyto le
plus grand espace de communication du
monde afin de mieux rêver le futur sur
les particuliers
du lard de dieu big m puis tranquille